できるます
できますね
こんにちは
私はハラー智彦と申しますラーメンの一風堂という会社で働いています
今日はの皆さんにラーメンのお話をしに行き
きたんですけど
ご飯食べてきましたか
ちょっと最初にあのラーメン亭愛顧に行く
これって
ちょっと思いますよね
ちょっとその間に質問します
ここ1年間でラーメンを食べて食べたことがないという方ちょっと手をあげてみて
いただきますか
1年この1年ラーメンは食べてないよという方
8人ですね
この1週間でラーメンを食べたなーっていう形体を上げてみてください
結構居ますね67人ぐらいですね
今日私がお話しに来たのはこのラーメンという
とても人々を魅了してしまうスープと
men 党
おかずが一緒になった食べ物のお話をさせていただきます
そしてそのお話を聞いて頂いた時に
何かいつも自分がこう固定概念で見ていた
こういうものだと思っていたものが実は違う角度から見ると
a そんなことになるんだこんな楽しみ方があるんだ
そんな風にして新しい発見を皆さんと共有できたらいいなって思っています
ラーメンの種類は日本中どこにでもあります
皆さんのご出身地濃
全然違うラーメンがありませんか北は北海道札幌味噌ラーメン
太麺
南の吸収は細めん豚骨
こんな風にしていろんな国でいろんな味わいのラーメンが楽しまれています
例えばこの高田のオバマ高田馬場だけで調べると
ラーメンを出しているお店の数はどれぐらいだと思いますか
どれぐらいだと思います
高田馬場だけで調べると何店舗ぐらいあるでしょ
を200店舗よっぽどラーメンを好きですねー
92店舗です
隣の池袋行きますかもう少し大きな街になります
230店舗でてきました
日本全国では3万5000件ぐらいのラーメン屋さんがあるというふうに言われてい
ます
そして今やいろんなお店でラーメンをメニューの一部として出しているんですね
その数を数えあのかカウントしましたらもっともっと多くの数があるはずです
3600なんでしょうこの数字
先ほど僕は申し上げました3万5000件がだいたい1
日本中にあるラーメン屋さんのそう東端の数なんですけど
3,600円これはですね1年間にオープンするラーメン屋さんの数なんです
しかしこの数字は同じく1年間に潰れてしまうラメやの数でもあると言われています
1日に10件新しく笑顔でオープンします
1日に10件涙とともにクローズします
こんなに激しい競争の食べ物のビジネスがラーメンのビジネスです
僕が今働いている会社一風堂という会社は福岡にあります福岡が発祥の会社です
1985年30年前に
産声をあげました30年前に
福岡で楽しまれていたラーメンというものは豚骨ラーメンです
2 no 褒めですね
当時9歳
ブタさんの骨をずーっと煮込むとものすごく匂いがします
その匂いが入っちゃねえって福岡も方達は大喜びして召し上がるんですが知らない人
からするとなんだこの匂いとなりがお家だったら大変なことになりますね
そして汚い汚い店の方がうまいんだよ
なんかもうゴールがっていうようなお店がとても多かったんですね
そして強いんですだいたいらー皆さんの写真見るとこうしてますね
愛らしい
お部屋だってよ
こういうお店には女性は行きたがりませんでした
ラーメン好きなんだけどあまり行きたくないなぁって
そんな時にこの我々の会社の会長なんですが
河原成美と言います
乗り女性が来ないの女性ラーメン好きなのに
じゃあ女性や大臣されて女性が好きだなって思うようならー皆さんをつくったらみんな
女性くるとって
そんな風にして女性に喜んでもらうよって
そういう気持ちで作ったラーメン屋さんが
一風堂でした
まず味くさいというものを取り除こうと
福岡では臭いラーメンの方が美味しいという固定概念がありました
でもそこに臭くない手法をとりの突端取り入れました
これ骨です
皆さんによりも子供大きな胴回りの寸胴鍋というものの中に
生成したお水を入れまして軟水にするんですね柔らかい水にするんです
そして2さんの背骨あるいは頭足首
いろんなパーツごとの骨をそれぞれにですね一番美味しいエキスが出てくるタイミング
が違うんです
そのもうそれぞれにに小蜜煮込みまして15時間くらいグツグツ煮込みます
そうするとこんなクリーミーシルキー
少し奄美のある
スープが取れるんですねこれを毎日やるんです
なんと1回目に出てくるとてもちょっと濃ゆいものは捨てるんですね
他のラーメン屋さんからそんなにやってんのって
いうぐらいのことを僕たちはしていますでも骨ってすごいんですよ
硬いんですこの硬い骨の向こう側に美味しいエキスが待っているんですね
赤丸白丸
ラーメンの味ではなくて色で私たちは表現をしました
とんこつラーメンだけじゃなくてですね沢山のラーメンを作っています
ちゃんぽんと言いますね回線が入っていますこれコンソメヌードルです
この真ん中にあるチャーシュー声ローストビーフですね
ゴージャスですね
お稲荷さんのように見えるご飯のブロックあのボールに見えるんですがこれフランス
パンです
フランス産の小麦をフランスのような硬いを水で作った pant men
兄弟ですね
こんなコンソメヌードルも作っていますこれフランスの2つ星シェフさんと一緒に作り
ました
これは大ストレーで出しているラーメンですこれも
チャーシューの代わりに
シュリンプが大きなシュリンプが入っています
カレーのラーメンもありますね黒い色をしています
ラーメンなんてジャンクなものじゃないか
肉が好きな早死にする奴のくいもんだろうってそういうふうに人もいますが
ベジタリアンヌードルも作っているんです完全に植物性のものでしか作っていません
例えばこれなんかもベジタリアンヌードル
こっちはですね
オーストラリアと入力で召し上がりますこちらは1日限定のものたんですだったんです
がこの黒いスープはコーヒーでできています
少しサワーの感じがするお酢が入っていたビネガーがですね入ったりしてすごく実は
おいしいんですよ
こんな風に一つのラーメンというものでも食べられないよーって思ってた方にも喜んで
もらえるそんな魔力が粗めにはあります
今年の夏冷たいこんな樹齢の入ったら名を出します
1日だけです
リップ道はこうしたフォーシーズンズに1回ずつ1日だけ1店舗でしか食べられない
ようなラーメンを作っています
クレイジーですね
味が美味しいだけだと3600円の中に入っちゃうんですね
潰れる方の
味はいいんだけどさなんかねえってそんな経験ありませんでしょうか
器にもこだわっています有田焼です
有田焼って通常絵が書いてあるんですね
なんで有田焼を使うのか美しいから
そしてタフだから
温かみのあるぬくもりがあるから
一風堂にはですね1ヶ月1万人以上のお客さんがお見えになります多い店だと3万人1
カ月にです
1[ __ ]3[ __ ]の器はありませんから何回も使い回します
ディ商社の中でものすごい高熱の熱投に現れ
重ね合わされてそれでもチップすることなく長く使い続けられる
これは骨を煮込むのと同じぐらいの長さ16時間焼いてますみなさんお風呂に入るとき
の温度って41度とか
夏になると39度で
よねー
この有田焼は正真正銘の有田焼は
1300度を3時間でします ih でできないんですね
比例やりますが集いがかかります限界1個2000円します
100均でも買えるようなラーメン罰が本当のビジネスで使うとき
美しさ温かさタフネスそういったものでも器でも私たちをお客さんを大事にモテなそう
そんな気持ちをしています
お店座って頂くお店召し上がって頂くお店スタッフが働くお店は2位だという概念が
あります
これ大名の1号店ですね福岡ですこんなお店があります
どうでしょう皆さんがよく行くラーメンのお店
こんな
お店って近くにありますか
そしてもう一論人です
今海外にも出ていてこの後話しますが日本のラーメン屋さんが流行っている
なぜかっていうとですね文社えっ
ガラガラと開けるとああこんにちはいらっしゃいませんそんな風に暖かく元気よく迎え
てくれることが外国の方達からするとわーおってなるそうです
目配り気配り
心配りこういうホスピタリティおもてなしというものが
ごはんを食べるところでも得られるホテルではなくてもです
どうでしょう
親だってよ
で言ってる人たちと明らかに違うでしょ
だからラーメンなんてって思っているんだけど実はこんなこともできちゃうってことな
んですね
そしてその
美味しい感じがいい
でもそれ器にこだわってるそれだけでも
3600円潰れてしまうこのハードなコンペティションの中で生き抜くのは大変なん
です
商いをさせていただいている地域
その地域に喜んでもらうためにいらっしゃいませと言って待つのではなくごめん
くださいませと言って小学校の体育館にお邪魔しています
ボランティアの食育出前授業です
僕も2014年の24dec
家族をほっぽり出してクリスマスイブにですね
小平の小学校の体育館でこの事業をやっていました
ラーと並ぶこんな風にして寸胴鍋そこにお店だしている
スーッと
持って来ましてですねラーメンを茹でて粉からギョーザを作る食べる喜び
働く喜び作る喜びそういったものを子どもたちに教えています
担任の先生でもない先生が会談はいいですかって何回も並び直すっていうのも名物に
なっています
こういった活動を日本でしていましたら海外に出て行きたくなりました
2008年ニューヨークに進出した時にラーメン屋じゃなくてもう1回ラーメン屋の
概念をちょっと変えをよっ
豆腐にしたらいいかなーって考えた挙句に出てきた答えが
ラーメンダイニングでした直感でやっているように聞こえるかもしれませんが実は
スゴイ
ユニリーバや p & g がやっているような調査をしています
ラーメン屋さんが単品ビジネスだとするとラーメンダイニングは
コースビジネスです20分でくってさよならって言って帰って行くラーメン屋さんの巣
ビジネスモデルがこちらでは2時間もお酒を呑みおつまみを食べて食べて
最後にラーメンで締めて買え
そんなに時間のコースでゆったりと満足していただくこんなビジネスモデルを
ニューヨークでしています
これ全部ポーション小さいんですね
これ野郎どもに喜んでもらいたくてこんなオシャレにはしてません
ニューヨークの女性たちがデートで
あるいは接待でビジネスミーティングで使っていただけるようにレンゲに以下のあの
海老のフリットを乗せてそっと
口元でエレガントに召し上がれるような小さなサイズにしています
なぜか
女性に着て欲しいからです
ニューヨークの店内はこんな感じですアップビートの曲が流れながら
ワイングラスには日本史が注がれていきます
シンガポール
ソウル本湖
シドニ
カウンターあるねえ
いいねぇラッパラーメンはカウンターだよねこれバーカウンターなんですね
2時間待たせますからまだ通って言ってる前にお酒でもいかがですかって言ってその
都度その都度チャリンチャリンですね
お腹が付いた頃にお席へご案内されて美味しく料理を召し上がっていただきます
台北
シャア
桑ラルーン2
バンコクにまあ manila philippines ですね
そしてジャカルタ a
去年ロンドンにオープンしました
去年の1月にパリでラーメンイベントをしました
ラーメンって何なのってよく知らない方のほうが多かったはずです
そこにこの行列ご覧くださいこれラーメンに並んでるんですね
ラーメンを召し上がる前におつまみとして焼き鳥やお寿司を出しました
どういうことでしょうね下克上ですねラーメンなんてってきた人たちがお寿司を最初に
ラーメンの前座で食べるんですね
小さくて可愛いなんて言われながら
テーブルの上には焼酎や japanese は委員としてのお酒が振る舞われます
寒空の下小雨降る中こんな風に舞っています
2015年の夏今年の夏にパリにオープンさせます
女性に着てほしいと思っていたその光景がパリでも生まれようとしています
男性もガッツリ食べてますねお箸を上手に使いながら
同じように子どもたちを呼んでラーメンを作る楽しさ
食べる喜びを一緒に味わっていますこれ
ラーメンの麺を作っているんですパスタマシンで結構キコキコってやると
麺線になって出てきますそれを茹でて一緒に食べるんですね
上手にできましたね
いっぱいのお店があるけど結局喜んでもらうその相手っていうのは一人なんですね
ですから私たちは一人に目の前の人を喜ばせようって喜んでもらいたいっていう気持ち
で今をお伝えしてきたような器もお店も
そして地域の人たちをも巻き込んで幸せを届けています
今日私はこの石英壇上でラーメンについてのお話をしました
でもこれ実はラーメンだけにはだけに当てはまるものではないです
何か皆さんが新しいビジネス新しい学び新しいプロダクトを開発する新しい友達と
付き合う
そんな時にこういうものだって思い込んで何か
見過ごしているこの見逃してる事ってひょっとしたらあるかもしれません
やってみたら簡単だったなぁとか思いのほか楽しかったなぁって
食べてみたらうまいじゃないかって
そういった固定概念を
限界を外して
違う角度から見てみたら例えばラーメンではこんな風になっていますって
そんなお話をさせていただきました
食べ物だけじゃなくていろんな人間関係もそうかもしれません
違う角度で見てみる
美乳アング
そんな
そんなスタイルをそんな目の持ち方をしてみると
面白い毎日が開けてくるんじゃないかなあなんて期待していますご静聴ありがとう
ございました